AEsthetics of code
Jan Krutisch
[Applause]
JAN: Thank you very much.
It's always an honour to speak at this conference,
and for me it's the second time, that kind
of amazes me.
Anyway, so how many of you have actually read
the description of the talk?
Okay, so there's this thing in there where
I say my presentation will contain nothing
but code, and as you can clearly see I'm already
tricking you because this is actually code.
You can take this, you can execute it in your
browser console and it's thanks to works of
a friend of mine, Martin Kleppe, who presented
this at JSConf 2013, and it basically turns
arbitrary JavaScript code into this weird
thing that only has six different characters,
I think, and it's completely oblivious to
white space, so I was able to turn it down
into these things that actually resemble title
slides.
And I was speaking yesterday to someone who
mentioned that in the title on the schedule
page, there's actually - I was using AE, like
the Danish use all the time, and it's not
in here because I didn't have it in my talk
title, the organisers came up with it and
I thought I need to fix this but the problem
is that encoding that takes up a lot more
space so it doesn't really fit the title screen.
Speaking of Martin's work I just want to quickly
point out what I don't really want to talk
about.
First of all, this.
You can look it up.
It's maybe aesthetic in its own way but it's
not very practical probably, and also this
is not practical.
I love this.
It has also been presented as JSConf 2013
and it is very beautiful, it has its ownaesthetic
but again is not very practical.
You can learn a lot by analysing what Martin
does here but it's not very helpful for day-to-day
stuff so I'm going to talk about other things
and the first thing I want to talk about is
programming languages versus natural languages,
and if you have been here on the talk before
mine, there was this idea of turning natural
language into something that computers can
understand, and I find this approach very
cool.
I think it makes sense to always keep in mind
that programming languages ... [sound problem]
... can turn natural language into something
that computers understand.
[Sound problem] ... pretty controversial example.
So how many of you know what this is, where
this is from?
So this is the official npm coding style guide,
a talk of it, which talks about the comma
first syntax.
Don't yell at me yet.
So I find this interesting.
I find - so I personally completely, you know,
I would never write this this way.
But for me it's just a different set of - yes,
I don't know, conventions that have different
drawbacks and different benefits from what
I would normally write, so I don't have a
huge issue with this, but in defence of this
I read a blog post that some of you may have
read at the time, it's pretty old, where he
says - I'm paraphrasing - don't compare JavaScript
to the English language.
JavaScript is not English.
So the argument that punctuation should be
at the end is silly.
I read that and had a pretty strong reaction
because I think this is a weird way of thinking
of this.
We as humans are used to reading natural language
every day, of course as programmers we are
used to reading programming language every
day but I think most of the programming languages
are modelled after things we have in natural
languages as well, and that makes a ton of
sense so to me that argument was kind of:
no.
The irony in the story, of course, is that
I wanted to - because this is just an example
from the style guide and then I wanted to
look up actual [sound problem] ... and I was
in for a surprise because I don't follow that
very closely, and obviously since 2015 ... interesting,
but the coding style is still out there so
if anyone from npm is here that might be something
you want to look at, more maybe I should - I
don't know.
So speaking of closeness to natural languages,
here is an example.
I'm a Ruby programmer - I'm sorry, don't shoot
me.
I also write Ruby.
And to me this is a perfect example of how
a language can look like that tries to mimic
natural language in some opponents.
Please ignore the puts.
Puts is a terrible choice for something - you
know, what does that even mean?
But ten times do, and then do something, that's
something I can show to - I almost said my
Mum, which is terrible.
Don't do that.
So you can show that to anyone who is not
familiar with programming and it will make
sense to them, and so I think this is a very
elegant example, a very aesthetic example
of how code can actually look, and just an
exercise for you to do in your head: turn
this into JavaScript.
You would probably use a 4 loop which is one
of the constructs in JavaScript that probably
resemble natural language the least, I would
say.
Another example.
This is Python.
I could have chosen CoffeeScript but I didn't
want it upset everyone in the audience, so
Python is one of those significant white space
languages and interestingly I looked it up
on Wikipedia, and it is termed offside languages.
Who has heard that before?
A few people.
Explain that to an American who calls this
thing soccer; interesting choice of words.
Anyway, I just found that funny.
So the thing I want to point out here is in
slightly modern typesetting, so since we are
doing typesetting, we use indentation for
grouping and categorising things, for building
a hierarchy of things, and the one thing that
we never do in typesetting is actually writing
something at the end that kind of closes down
that block.
You never do that.
So I think Python made an interesting choice
and it works for Python because it turns this
thing into something that is still pretty
good to read and it follows a convention that
has been set a few hundred years ago of how
to do hierarchies.
So there's two problems I see with these kind
of languages and the first one is actually
probably not a problem, so at some point I
don't know if he has coined that, but DHH,
the creator of Rails, used the term syntactic
vinegar and I like that term, so if you imagine
you have code that longer than your screen
in a language like this and you scroll down
and suddenly it's like: where am I?
Where does this close?
I have no idea.
I'm completely lost in indentation and so
the language or the syntax punishes you for
actually doing a thing that you shouldn't
do in the first place which is writing long
functions, and I found that kind of interesting.
The other issue I have with it is that, to
me, it always looks a little bit like this.
So it's kind of off balance in a way.
It never returns.
This is weird.
So yes, that's significant white space.
This is interesting, so just a quick show
of hands, who likes the first thing better?
Who likes the other thing better?
Okay, everyone else doesn't have any reaction
to that, which is fine.
So to me at first this was - that's the JavaScript
way and the other is the Ruby way.
There's a complete family of languages like
Ruby, Python and others that join things together
with an underscore and there's a whole family
of languages that uses the camel case kind
of thing.
What's the difference?
Turns out there's a study - I only found this
one, but interesting enough - that kind of
tried to find out which works better in the
context of how precise can you - how is the
precision of detecting things and how quickly
can you actually read this?
And it turns out that snake case is same precision
but significantly faster and to me after thinking
about it for a minute that totally makes sense,
so if you know how the brain and the eye together
parses words and sentences, you are not reading
character by character, you are basically
reading shapes of words, and so making out
the shapes of the words in a functioning like
that is significantly harder if you just jam
them together and put some large characters
in there.
The underscore actually looks pretty familiar
to the human eye because it's almost like
a space, and there's almost - the underscore
almost takes up no room so there's no shape
to detect in a way.
That's my own almost unscientific explanation
for it anyway.
So why did languages choose one or the other?
That's an interesting question.
I have no answer for that, of course.
To close this down, here is something, you
know, that's from an example from a blog post
that I read during preparing for this talk
by Joseph Wynne who talks about readability
in code and this is another thing where actually,
you know, thinking about how we write natural
languages can help a lot because this for
some reason is completely more readable.
You have all the blocks in there and you just
use paragraphs.
You know, it's a very simple thing and it
might sound really mundane and trivial but
I have seen code bases where this rule wasn't
applied and I don't mean Martin Kleppe's stuff
with that, or minified code.
The second thing I want to talk about really
quickly is the principle of least surprise,
which is something that influences language
design up to a point, and I have a very terrible
example for you that you will all know, like
who in here knows what's going wrong with
these lines of code?
Come on, show your hands, please!
OMG.
So all of these things are complete garbage.
They parse into things you don't want them
to be parsed into and they will all balk out
with terrible errors.
Why is that?
Because - I mean, it's JavaScript, so JavaScript
wants to have semicolons at the end of every
instruction.
Do you see any semicolons in here?
Well, I don't.
It's, of course, okay to write it because
we have this awesome feature called automatic
semicolon insertion, or ASI.
The problem is there are a few cases where
the ASI stuff simply doesn't know what to
do, and in this case I mean the worst example
is like the one in the middle where it turns
it into a division because, you know, there's
a variable and then there's a slash, so there
must be a division, and then everything goes
wrong, of course.
To me, this is like JavaScript's Achilles
heel in a way because to me, from an aesthetics
standpoint, all of this looks totally fine.
I've seen in your reaction that you think
too this should be valid code, but other languages
simply have different syntax rules that make
sure that something like this doesn't happen,
and JavaScript at some point decided that
it's okay to say: okay, we need semicolons
but then we don't but then there are weird
cases and that makes it really hard to look
at this piece of code and say, "This is wrong",
or, "This is right", and if you are an experienced
JavaScript programmer or if you are exlint
for example, you can say it and say this is
wrong, and you can balk out and say: please
change this.
One way is to prefix all the second lines
with semicolons.
Looks really beautiful.
So another trivial thing, so I like to close
down the blogs with trivial things obviously,
if you can see it, what's wrong with this?
Does this really calculate a sum?
No, it doesn't.
That's like the most trivial example for validating
the principle of least surprise that you can
probably come up with.
It's like: nobody would do that, right?
But then you just think about it, how it happens,
and code bases, and you have this method or
a function that does a certain thing and you
use it in 30 places all over your code and
then a new business requirement comes in and
you kind of slightly change the function,
that it does things a little bit different
like not changing from a sum to a difference,
but something more subtle, but the name only
half matches what's going on now.
Do you really want to go into 30 places and
change the name?
Do you have automatic tools for that?
And so that's just - don't do that.
Don't leave it in like that.
Change it to something that's correct.
That's what I'm going to tell you.
So who knows what - just out of curiosity,
who knows what language this is?
It's Louvre [?] so you know, function and
then this weird looking syntax.
Number three, expressiveness.
This is one of my favourite subjects.
I like expressive languages so that's why
I'm starting with this.
Who knows what this is?
Hands up, shout it at me?
Exactly, it is the syntax definition for Lisp.
It's pretty small, isn't it?
That's amazing.
So there's this other thing I want to show
you.
Don't bother to read it.
This is a parser definition for the Ruby syntax.
It's not like the parser definition., it's
just a library that parses Ruby
into abstract syntax trees, and I already
sped that up two times.
It's like 2500 lines or so.
It's quite different to Lisp, isn't it?
So now we are done.
Now let's look at some code examples.
This is like the prototypical Fibonacci sequence
definition for Lisp for recursive Fibonacci
calculation.
And I'm not used to Lisp so I look at this
and go: hmm, I don't think I like this very
much, and to me it's like, you know, if all
you have - lists - everything looks like a
hammer.
So yes, it's very uniform and if it wouldn't
be correctly indented it would make no sense
to me.
Interesting thing though about the indenting,
because Lisp syntax is so simple, it's really
trivial to build a tool that will autoform
a Lisp code for you which is almost impossible
for Ruby code, for example.
So here is the Ruby example, and to me as
a Ruby programmer, and probably also to you
as a JavaScript programmer, this makes a ton
more sense so there's syntax to define the
end and the beginning of a function.
There's syntax to return something, there's
an if thing which is kind of weird for JavaScript
programmers, but it's like inherited from
Perl and I don't particularly like it but
it works.
Yes, there's just so much syntax in there
in contrast to the thing before that I think
it just goes to show that while Lisp people
always say that having syntax actually makes
things more complex, it also makes things
more readable, I think, for the most part
at least.
So here is another example.
This is an incomplete example before you yell
at me for something that could happen, in
Ruby on res, for example, and it's a definition
for a user table or a user object that has
a relationship to photos, so users have many
photos, and this looks - to me, this looks
quite elegant and it looks like a declaration.
There's a reason for that because there are
- the method call that is in there technically
doesn't have the parentheses around it and
that's a Ruby thing.
You can just leave out the parentheses.
You shouldn't do that all the time but for
something like this it makes a ton of sense
because it is a declaration more or less,
but technically internally it isn't.
That's just an example to show you how flexible
syntax rules can really improve the readability
and the expressiveness of something.
The next thing I want to talk about is punctuation.
Who recognises the language in here?
Yes, exactly.
So this is Pascal.
I'm sorry, it's - the most important thing
is at the bottom.
I should have changed that slide.
So there are two things in here that I find
interesting.
The first one is the assignment operator of
Pascal.
Who loves the assignment operator in Pascal?
Right.
Because it is a mathematically somewhat adequate
description of an assignment whereas if you
compare two values in Pascal you are using
the equals sign, which means that something
is equal, and for some reason in almost every
other language we do this weird thing where
we use two equals sign for comparison, or
even three, and that's kind of - yeah, I like
that.
The other thing is right at the bottom, and
I'm sorry if you can't see that, but there's
a full stop at the end of the programme.
I just admire that simplicity.
It's like: end, full stop.
That's it.
Punctuation.
There are a few languages that use punctuation
- I'm sorry for another Ruby example.
You have one which basically adds an exclamation
mark to the method and most of the time it's
a version on a method that does something
more dangerous than another method, in this
case it's the self-modifying method in contrast
to a method that would return a copy, and
then we have the question mark methods which
denotes that it will return and that's nice
because it allows you to return things like
"is empty" or "does not have contents", and
all jammed together with camel case so that's
pretty cool.
You can, of course, put this completely over
the top and then you would end up with something
like this, so who knows what this is?
It's the programming language.
Actually, it's "a" programming language, it's
APL.
And it's a very old language and it uses all
kinds of mathematical characters to express
things and just think about how weird it would
be to input this language, and so back in
the days, that was before computer screens
were really a thing so they had to come up
with a printer head that would be able to
print these things and of course also you
needed a special keyboard to be able to put
this in and, yes, that's probably overdoing
it a bit with the symbols there.
Another thing that improves expressiveness
is operating overloading and I don't even
have an idea if this is really operator overloading
technically, but in Ruby you can just overwrite
the array accessor and that's pretty nice
because you can do various things with it.
There are other languages that do operator
overloading.
If you haven't heard of - like, who knows
what this is?
It's a language that has been talked a lot
about a few years back and I haven't heard
a lot since.
It's Dart, and Dart has operator overloading.
That's how it looks and it's pretty nice because
you can just take two objects, add them together
and something meaningful comes out of that,
and that just makes for more beautiful code,
I think.
This is Ruby examples again, like having - being
able to do a substring on something just by
adding square brackets to it.
I think this really makes a difference in
how expressive a language is.
Number 4: shared aesthetics.
I am going to close out with this.
So there's lots of stuff I have talked about
and I have also talked a lot about - I've
written in my description that this thing
- Remy was talking about, like, nobody agrees
with you in terms of aesthetics.
I have something that we probably all agree
on.
And that's that this is probably not a good
idea.
I stole this from a tweet.
I kind of like the attitude behind this.
Like, you can actually write Java code without
curly braces and semicolons, except that you
can't.
Yeah.
I see from your reaction you are agreeing
with this.
What I find interesting about the JavaScript
community though is that there doesn't seem
to be a strong shared understanding of how
JavaScript should look like.
Other languages do it a little bit differently.
For example, we have Python which has in PEP8
- PEP is like their proposal system for new
language features and PEP8 is obviously one
of the first texts written by the man himself,
Guido, and it writes meticulously how you
should write in Python, how you should index
things, all that stuff, and if you are a newcomer
to Python you just read that thing and internalise
it and you are done.
That's pretty cool.
You might not agree with everything in there
but that's how things are done here so maybe
that's not so bad.
We have a similar thing in Ruby.
It's the community style guide.
It's not really official but people start
to adhere to it due to the fact that the guy
who wrote the first thing here also wrote
a pretty good linter.
That's a nice trick.
So in JavaScript we have something like this,
which is the Crockford style guide, also relatively
detailed, how you should write your JavaScript,
and I guess like 90% of the community nowadays
disagrees with it, which is fine.
Then we have this, Standard.
Who loves Standard?
Ah, just a few hands.
Interesting.
So Standard.js is pretty cool because it just
defines a more modern set of how JavaScript
should look like, but I can't get over this,
I'm sorry.
Yes, I've no idea.
I would love to know why this is.
Probably someone can explain it to me later
on, but what I wanted to point out is that
there are a set of languages and I think Go
were not the first but they kind of have the
strongest stance on this, like if you are
writing Go and you are not using the official
Go formatter, you are just doing it wrong.
Everyone else is using that, and so the Go
community also doesn't have problems with
figuring out how you should actually write
Go code.
And there are a ton of other things and the
last thing I want to point out is Elm.
Who loves Elm?
A few hands.
I like Elm.
I've never built anything spectacular in it,
but I kind of like the approach and I also
like the approach that it doesn't come with
this huge baggage of I have to know what monads
and endofunctors are before I can actually
start writing functional code.
I like that approach, in the communication
first of all, and elm-format does this weird
thing, and with this I kind of would like
you to marvel at the irony of an aesthetics
presentation that begins and ends with comma
first code, and I want to close with the reason
that I wear this T-shirt is that I'm currently
trying to build a greenkeeper that works for
Ruby so if you are also writing Ruby code
and not only writing JavaScript code, please
come talk to me afterwards, and with that,
thank you.
[Applause]